[Musique]
donc
[Musique] [Musique]
[Musique]
nous générons beaucoup de déchets à partir du
jardin de bananes,
alors je n'arrêtais pas de penser que si ces déchets pouvaient être
utilisés
pour les textiles, nous pourrions
fournir
un produit durable au monde et
ensuite  j'ai commencé le voyage
pour développer des fibres à partir de textiles,
je veux dire des
fibres textiles à partir des déchets
[Musique] [
Musique] [Musique] [
Musique] [
Applaudissements] [
Musique]
[Musique]
les extensions de cheveux que nous fabriquons sont
hautement biodégradables
après utilisation  nos dames iront les enfouir
dans le sol et ils deviendront du fumier
pour leurs légumes
ouais alors on essaie de remplacer
ce qui se fait
avec des cheveux synthétiques comme les
cheveux naturels comme
[Musique]
nettoyer les tapis c'est très facile quand
on  quand vous essayez de les nettoyer,
ils reviennent étincelants de propreté
et presque comme neufs
et je suis définitivement revenu pour en acheter
un autre
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
donc [
Applaudissements] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous